I'm Homeland Security Secretary Janet
Napolitano I'd like to thank you for
tuning into the special web address
today November 25th marks the tenth
anniversary of the creation of the
Department of Homeland Security which
pulled together nearly two dozen federal
agencies and departments under the
control of a new single entity its
responsibilities include running the
u.s. border patrol to Plum Island Animal
Disease Center to FEMA DHS is the third
biggest happenin agency but are we any
better off because of its existence here
are three reasons to get rid of DHS come
join the homeland security team in the
months immediately following the 9/11
attacks of 2001 President George W Bush
initially resisted calls to create a new
high-level bureaucracy that would be
laid on top of current activities he was
right to recognize that coordinating
existing agencies would have been better
and smarter
unfortunately he caved into pressure to
create a massive new Department come
join the homeland security team to read
the titles of Government Accounting
Office or Gao analyses of Homeland
Security is to be constantly reminded
that DHS is never quite on top of its
game recent reports include DHS requires
more disciplined investment management
to help meet mission needs DHS needs
better project information and
coordination among four overlapping
grant programs and agriculture
inspection program has made some
improvements but management challenges
persist
come join the homeland security team
last year Homeland Security spent a
whopping 60 billion dollars a figure
that will doubtlessly increase in coming
years the construction of its new
headquarters the single largest project
ever undertaken by the General Services
Administration will cost at least four
billion dollars and is already years
behind schedule since breaking ground in
2009 since it's the holiday season
here's a bonus reason to get rid of the
Department of Homeland Security it also
runs the Transportation Security
Administration whose nasty reputation
for manhandling innocent travelers is
only slightly more annoying
then it's massive and undeserved growth
in personnel and cost over the past
decade for raisin TV I'm Nick Gillespie